Mind Your Decisions. I'm Presh Talwalkar
Start with the trapezoid where these two sides are congruent
The trapezoid has angles of 80 degrees 80 degrees 100 degrees and 100 degrees
Now join congruent trapezoids to form a closed ring
How many trapezoids are needed in total to form a closed ring?
This is said to be one of the toughest questions asked on the SAT, which I saw on a thread on Quora
Pause if you'd like to give this problem a try and when you're ready keep watching to learn how to solve this problem
So, how can we solve this problem
We can actually simulate it on the computer quite nicely
We can actually place trapezoids adjacent to each other until we form a closed ring
We then just need to count the total number of trapezoids and there we go. We get our answer of 18
However, you won't be able to use computer software on the test. So how do we solve it using pencil and paper?
Well, let's place adjacent trapezoids and then calculate this exterior angle around the closed ring
Since we have an 80 degree angle here
This exterior angle will be 180 minus 80 minus 80 which simplifies to be 20 degrees
Now we'll use a property of exterior angles in a polygon
The sum of the exterior angles will be equal to 360 degrees
Since 1 exterior angle is 20 degrees
we have n times 20 degrees is equal to 360 and therefore n is equal to 18 and
That will be our answer which exactly matches what we found before
What's more is we can use this method in the video to solve similar problems?
so I challenge you to this variation of the problem where one angle and the trapezoid is 60 degrees and
I challenge you to another variation where one angle is 75 degrees
How many trapezoids will be needed to form a closed ring?
Thanks for making Mind Your Decisions one of the best channels on YouTube.
As always, thanks for watching and thanks for your support.